Cory is with us in Pennsylvania hi Cory
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show oh hi
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up um so I just started recently
listening to your show and thank you for
the time you take to give out such sound
wisdom I really appreciate that I bought
your book the Total Money Makeover I
complete it baby step one and I'm in
baby step two and I just want to kind of
figure out my debts here I got the
snowball idea down so all my debts are
in collection except the one small
medical bill and my student loans and I
also have a lawsuit against me
a judgment I should say from credit card
debt collection agency
and I can't even make enough I can't
even keep up with the interest rate on
the payment and I just want to know how
to hang payments on that judgment I have
not because I kind of went into scum bag
status if you will and decided not to
pay my debts and then when I heard your
show God kind of pricked my heart and
you said this man's talking some stuff
in your life clearing my name it's on
the student loans right now uh it's in
deferral right now okay I'm just kind of
just got into baby step two and I'm just
getting everything situated okay good
and how much is the lawsuit for $5,000
right around $5,000 what's your
household income 35,000 a year and how
long is the lawsuit billion there this
was that I received the judgment on that
at the end of 2018 two years okay now
one year one year and some change okay
and how much does the student loan debt
just Oh a little over $8,000 okay good
all right so like $15,000 sets you free
right that's right yeah
thousand other months odd job
even if you spent what you're making now
on living thousand dollar Mossad job has
you a hundred percent debt free any here
right yeah it sounds right yeah thousand
times twelve yeah you're there baby you
got this okay oh good god I'm excited
for you there's a good times alright so
I would leave the student loans in
deferral and I'd take care that little
medical bill first the second thing is I
would save up two thousand dollars cash
very very quickly what you do this real
fast then once you call set a judgment
and say I was talking to my financial
coach and he said even though you're
broke they might work with you because
they might rather have some money now
since they had never gotten anything so
I don't have any money but I got two
thousand dollars if you want to take
that a settlement in full remember that
phrase if you want take that a
settlement in full we'll do a deal right
now and you'll probably be able to
settle it for somewhere around that okay
now you have to argue with them and
they've wine and they roll in the floor
and foam at the mouth and all this crap
but at you got to go through that a
little drama right but you'll get there
with the negotiation back-and-forth and
always blame it on your financial coach
said this is the thing cuz I'm your
financial coach and I just told you that
so it's a true statement okay and tell
them your financial coach said you
weren't allowed to go any higher than
that because you're too broke and you
only make thirty five thousand a year
and you got all this student loan debt
and this is this is just like a one-time
goodtime deal so take the money while
you can fast kind of kind of mess with
them you following me
yeah yeah now it's two things to
remember get it in writing the deal
what if it's not writing it didn't
happen you can tell credit card
collectors are lying if their mouth is
moving get it in writing if it's not in
writing it didn't happen
there was a myth and it needs to say
this amount settles this account in full
you keep of that piece of paper hardcopy
the rest of your life okay
okay and you know second thing is you
keep proof of the payment that you make
the rest your life and so the second
rule is no electronic access to your
checking account because if you tell
them two thousand dollars but you've got
three thousand in your account they're
cleaning your account out and then
you'll know the money for your rent so
then get it in writing and no electronic
access to your checking account you
and wire it to them you can do a prepaid
debit card off a different account you
can do stuff like that but no electronic
access to your main account because they
lie
okay then once you clear that up then
call the student loan people get on a
payment plan and plow your way through
that get an extra job get on the every
dollar budget you got this dude you've
got it you can do it this is the Dave
Ramsey show